to the international space station their
spacecraft successfully docked to the
station on monday evening and they
joined kate rubins who has been living
and working on board the station
for the past five weeks their docking
marked the start of the first crew
rotation flight of the u.s commercial
spacecraft
and begins a regular cadence of space
station missions
launching from the u.s aboard commercial
vehicles
it is so great to see you all on board
we'll go ahead and start with any
remarks that the crew would like to make
and then take questions for them for
media on the phone
please press star 1 to ask a question
and star 2 to withdraw your question if
it's already been asked
with that i will turn it over to the
crew
okay thank you um boy i'd say it
is fantastic to be up here
the the launch itself was was absolutely
incredible
um that vehicle really gets off the
ground and uh
and so it was exciting all the way up
and the ride was was very smooth so
it's uh you know i know we had a few
delays along the way
but we launched when we were supposed to
and and we got here when we were
supposed to so
um from crew one we just want to say
thank you again to
all of the folks at uh nasa at spacex
the dod
everybody that helped make that launch
uh successful
and uh we are really looking forward to
the next six months up here on the
international space station
here okay let's get started with q a
let's start with chris davenport with
the washington post
so hi guys it's great to see you my
question is for uh suici
this is now the third vehicle that
you've flown to space
i just wonder how resilience compared
to the soyuz and the shuttle thank you
hey chris thanks for the question for
the record
the dragon is the best it's a short
answer
and of course each vehicle has its own
uh uh
you know uh uh peculiarity but
uh i feel dragon is really ready to go
up
it's really uh it's fun to fun to ride
and the two days and uh they're going
this really
remarkable memories so i'm really happy
to be here again
awesome okay let's go to joey roulette
with reuters
okay we'll come back to joey how about
russell pounds with pacific
rim media
uh good morning folks great to see you
uh this is russell i'm calling from
alaska today
uh a question for shannon and ribby
victor i understand you've taken
quite a few science experiments up to
the station along with the mini
already in progress which experiments do
you think might be most
surprising or meaningful to those of us
back on earth
you know that is a very good question um
and i'm not sure i have an answer for
you at this time
i we really haven't gotten into the
experiments we're still sort of getting
organized
and so i may have to wait a few weeks
before i answer that because i'm
honestly not sure what we've got going
in the next you know the next few months
okay let's go to david curley with
discovery channel
hey guys thanks for doing this uh could
you fill in a little more
about uh what the ride was like how did
it compare to what bob and doug
said the sounds the vibrations uh
did it match up pretty quick and kate
what did you tell the rookie
when he came through the hatch there you
were
waving your arms i'm just curious what
you said thank you
i was so excited to see ike's face
coming through that hatch
we've been thinking about this moment up
here uh together with the the two
sergeys
uh waiting for our four crewmates to
join him
and i think uh i said oh my gosh you're
here
we were we were just really really
excited to see them coming through the
hatch
and to welcome our friends to the
international space station
yeah and in terms of the the launch
itself uh you know i mentioned at the
beginning it was exciting ride
and that really doesn't do it justice to
be honest bob and doug described it
pretty well
um but to just when you're sitting there
on the rocket as it's going through the
fueling process
you know there's noises and vibrations
and it in many sense it just
it you can tell it wants to get off the
ground and particularly in those last uh
two three minutes as
the final fueling is happening and uh
and the strong bats retracted and things
of that nature it's
it's definitely ready to go and it it
just it leaped off
the pad it was amazing and right after
we about 40 seconds into the flight
you throttle back a little bit and you
definitely noticed that but then when it
was time to get going again it really
picked up
and yeah and it was it was really moving
uh staging is always pretty exciting i
think on any rocket and this one is no
different
uh there is uh when the when the first
stage uh
shuts off and and separates and then
that second stage kicks in
you definitely know that as well and
then this just slow steady build up in
g's all the way up into orbit
um but i tell you we were we were all
very excited
uh we were when we passed the 100
kilometer point we all said
welcome to space to ike because that's
certainly a big moment and i think it's
probably worthwhile to hear what ike
thought of
his first ride to space as well
yeah it's a great question and the short
answer is it was awesome i could sit
here and tell you for the entire
duration of this conference
how great the ride was but the staging
was dynamic the g's on the second stage
the second stage is much closer to our
spacecraft so you felt it it was much
more
up close and personal but we accelerated
for
several minutes and so the g just slowly
built in you definitely felt it and then
when that engine cut off and we were in
orbit i mean it's surreal i've seen tons
of pictures
but um you know when i first looked at
the out the window at the earth
it's hard to describe there are no words
there are no words to describe it it was
an amazing once-in-a-lifetime feeling
all right the next question will be from
marcia dunn
for associated press yes uh victor i
have a question for you if you don't
mind
what was your biggest surprise about the
launch and
having flown 3 000 and more than 40
aircraft how hard was it
to be hands off the whole time thank you
thank you interesting that's a great
question marcia and
and how you doing um so you know when i
first started training for this
30 months or so ago that was a big deal
to me i will tell you
on on the 15th or or greenwich mean time
on the 16th
it wasn't an issue at all the the rocket
the falcon 9 performed
superbly the way it was supposed to
dragon
performed superb um we had some things
to work through uh but we worked through
it as a crew
and i tell you what uh the thing that
surprised me the most and it's
interesting you reference you know
having three thousand hours and some
combat time flying high performance jets
the g was not the highest g i've ever
felt but it was for
probably the longest duration and so
that was a surprise and a fighter you
can't hold
you know four g's for several minutes
and not not most aircraft
and so that was a surprise um and again
once those uh the second stage cut off
and you're floating again i've been able
to feel that for a few seconds but to
have that for an extended period
was just truly amazing
okay let's go to jeff nguyen with cbs
los angeles
morning victor thank you for doing this
i hope you can take a question from me
you know i'm from your hometown earlier
in the week i got to speak to your
college wrestling coach coach cal
and your department director at cal poly
dr walsh and both of them said that they
literally cried
when they watched the launch
and you going up was like having them on
your back
uh what's it like for you to hear you
know your college instructors
speak of you uh with that much pride
and um you know what are you hoping to
to share with the
kids um you know from this mission
because i know that that's something
that's very important to you
as a girl dad
wow thank you for that great question um
you know girl dad a dad period i just i
hope that this
inspires people to literally and
figuratively look up i really think
having something to look up to now
especially
as we bring 2020 to a close it's just
something that we all need
and you know you mentioned two people
who mean so much to me and i could name
a ton more but you know coach cal
and dr walsh my advisor in undergrad
were um
huge inspirations to me and so to hear
that they were inspired by this i mean
you're about to make me cry that that
brought tears to my eyes just now
i was fortunate to see a shuttle launch
uh when i was still flying test
uh missions in the navy and and it did
it brought a tear to my eye it was just
such an amazing thing to think
those folks are leaving the planet for
for a while and it's hard again
another thing that's kind of a
life-changing event so to to share that
with them was was truly an amazing
opportunity thanks for the question
wow now we're all crying okay let's go
to tarik malik with space.com
hello and and good morning my question
is for the station veterans and for you
kate
uh i'm curious you know this is uh the
first time we've seen
a seven-member long-duration crew i'm
wondering is it
feel extra crowded uh are there lines at
the galley in the
uh and the the wc i'm just wondering
what you're hoping
with that extra person on board to
accomplish in terms of science and
research for the station
thanks tariq that's a great question and
i would say
it's crowded has got like some negative
connotations
this is busy in a great way there's
energy up here we've got
people zooming by you know hopper's been
working in the glove box
this morning somebody else is in another
module doing science
somebody else is on the exercise machine
so you can tell that there is
just so much going on on the space
station
and by having five of us up here now
we're able to really accomplish a huge
amount
of research and so there's some level of
maintenance that we always have to do on
the space station and so when you're
just
one person like me a lot of time gets
taken up just keeping this place running
now that we've got all of us the amount
of scientific
output that you're going to see from
this mission i think is absolutely
incredible
all right let's go to rachel joy with
florida today
hey everybody it was an amazing launch
thank you so much for
doing this today um we're just dying to
know
how you chose baby yoda as the zero g
indicator
and um how does he compare flying on the
falcon 9 versus the mandalorian
spacecraft thank you
wow yeah so the
you know each crew that's a the the zero
g
indicator is a has a long tradition that
crews have been able to pick those out
and um and so each crew has that
opportunity
and so that was one we we talked about
um we had just
uh started watching the series and um
it's hard not to like baby yoda
and you know it kind of ties in i i
think with um
the name of our spacecraft as well we
talk about resilience and you know it's
been a
it's been a tough year and uh you know
the fact that
they were able to spacex and nasa were
able to get our spacecraft ready to go
the rocket ready to go throughout this
year
throughout the pandemic and all of that
you know we were inspired
by by everybody's effort to do that so
that's why we named resilience
and we hope that it puts a smile on
people's face it
brings hope to them and and so baby yoda
does the same thing
i think everybody when you see him it's
hard not to smile and so it just seemed
appropriate
it seemed appropriate for our crew as
well we like to have a lot of fun
and we have been having a lot of fun um
and so again it was uh it was very
appropriate i think
i think the ride into space was uh was
probably a little rougher than baby yoda
was used to
compared to what he yards normally
okay thank you the next question will be
from nick samuel with vero news
hi everybody this question is for victor
glover
i know that you talked about uh your
first space flight experience
earlier uh so can you talk about how it
finally felt
to make it to the international space
station did you
did you have a sigh of relief or were
you unnerved
can you can you talk about that
wow nick that's a great question and you
know it's
it's so many different feelings it's
hard to explain it it really is hard to
put into words
the the the awe of seeing the space
station even over our video system
from dragon and then feeling the the
soft contact the slow deceleration as we
made contact with the station
and then making full contact and
pressurizing opening the hatch
seeing kate all of these emotions i mean
the happiness the relief but then
knowing that we've got work to do and
and wanting to contribute
and also getting used to space you know
i was i was very slow my brain
is constantly trying to figure out where
up is
and i don't know if it's because i'm a
new guy they made me sleep in the
ceiling so every time i pop my head out
the entire space station is upside down
so i just stay upside down as much as
possible
but that that i think requires extra
processing and so
everything else takes me so much longer
and so i'm trying to push through that
and get work done
but it is an interesting challenge that
i actually find slightly amusing
so it's been a whole bunch of emotions
and honestly i'm still
processing it i've been writing little
notes to myself and things in my journal
and hopefully i'll look back on and be
able to give you a better more concise
answer but
it is so many different feelings um but
but excitement is definitely one of them
that's fantastic okay let's go to mark
caro with
aviation week and space technology
good morning and thank you i want to
follow up on a question to
um to kate earlier and my question
is for uh mike and shannon what what do
you see
uh having five people in the uf segment
now what is your sense of
the environment and and the future of
having that many people
aboard to do all the maintenance and
research
yeah i can uh i'll start off and i'll
just say it's it's go time up here i
mean uh
this you know we came across a hatch
just a couple days ago i guess but it's
it's been pretty busy since we showed up
here so i think
uh the the folks on the ground um all of
the investigators out there
i think they've been waiting a long time
for this moment and
and so they've uh they've got our
calendars full already and i think
it's a good thing we are going to see
just how much science can come out of
this space station and it's a lot
uh but it takes a lot of extra work too
because you know there is limited space
there's limited com capabilities
uh there's limited video capabilities
and so you have to coordinate all of
those kind of things together
and and that's going to be challenging i
think it's going to take us a few
a few weeks to get our feet under us and
figure out how how five people are
actually able to
to work around here without running into
each other the whole time
and all of that but it is pretty
exciting
yeah just to add to that um you know
people have asked about whether or not
we've got
uh uh you know collisions on the
exercise equipment or the whc but really
it's the traffic jams that we have going
through the modules trying to get from
where we need to be from one place to
the other
so it's definitely um you can tell that
it's a lot fuller here
instead of three people on this side
fight people but
everybody's right is we're gonna get a
lot of work done which is really good
for
all the science that goes on in the
world
okay let's take the next question from
robert perlman with collect space
hi um a question for mike hawkins um
you described how dragon performed as a
spacecraft how is it performing as a
bedroom
have you set up camp inside dragon as
you expected and
um i know you had some temperature
issues on the way up getting it warm
enough
have you experienced that again
yeah that's that's a great question and
and to be quite honest um
i'm not quite there yet because the
first thing that we had to do
um after arriving is we had to get all
of the cargo off
and then we had to move a lot of
emergency equipment on board as well and
so
that took us a little bit of time to do
that and i didn't really want to try and
get set up
in dragon until all of that movement was
done and
and i could kind of figure out where the
right place to put the sleeping bag was
and
and a few items i'll take inside there
uh you know as far as the temperature uh
they've
they've been very generous um and kind
of dropped the temperature down a little
bit right where we
are and this happens to be where the
other uh the crew quarters are
and and so that's to make sure that that
our um that resilience stays cool for me
it's probably been a little bit chilly
uh but but i've certainly been
comfortable
we're probably gonna have to talk about
the temperature a little bit more here
um but but overall i think it's gonna
work out just fine um
you know it is a it's a roomy vehicle
and and so um
you know i'm looking forward to to the
next six months
and uh we'll see uh probably it's gonna
take me a few more days to really get
settled in
all right let's go to stephen clark with
space flight now
hi stephen clark for space flight now i
want to follow up on my
an earlier question from chris davenport
for ceviche gucci
um what makes dragon the best and can
you give us a little
window into life aboard the ship for 27
hours on the way to the space station
and how cramped is it compared to uh
your experience with soyuz and space
shuttle
thanks thanks
well uh my other crew member already
described but
the dragon was fun to fly it's uh
it's really kind of uh
they wanted to go dragons really wanted
to go to space
the the engine was really crisp and
clear and the feel the vibration
and definitely defies the gravity and
brings up the space in the matter of
nine minutes or so and uh and the
difference mainly is the
the feel of the all the plumbing all
those the fueling
uh that you actually feel the all the
uh the lucky liquid oxygen going into
the tank
a couple minutes before the flight and
also the
the field the thruster vibration sound
and also the small
uh uh orange orientation control
injectors
since i'm sitting by the window seat i
feel the jet is firing
right next to my head which is actually
a good sign
so uh uh obviously this is uh feels
like you are actually inside the dragon
bringing us up to space so that was
quite a feeling
okay let's take the next question from
jackie goddard with the times of london
hello and congratulations on another
successful crew dragon flight
you'll make space flight look so easy
but we know space is hard
what would be your best tip to future
space travelers
about how to prepare for living and
working in space particularly those
who may not be career astronauts i guess
basically my question
is is there anything important that tom
cruise needs to know
i think if people are going to come to
space and not be career astronauts
i think the biggest tip you could have
is to be
organized because if you're not
organized you're going to lose your
stuff
[Music]
in
okay let's take a question from joey
roulette with reuters
hey uh
i just want to follow up on the bedroom
crew dragon question
um was there any competition for who
gets to sleep in crew dragon and mike
since that'll be you
um what what i guess will your sleeping
arrangement look like and what kind of
tests
and data will you plan to get from that
thanks
yeah uh we were talking about you know
if you know rock paper scissors there's
also another version
called the gunman guerilla man karate
man so
[Laughter]
but uh actually you know there was a
tradition that when the shuttle used to
to come up and bring components and
supplies to the space station i think
the commander always ended up sleeping
on
on the shuttle um and it just it just
felt right that that's uh where i was
supposed to uh to go
um and and so you know we talked about
it as a crew a little bit
um and everybody was uh you know
everybody would be willing to sleep
wherever right you're in space and so
you're not going to complain
you don't want to complain uh about
about where your sleeping quarters are
but uh so
um in terms of you know what we're going
to get out of it
you know most of the time while we're
we're docked dragon is going to be in
what we call a quiescent mode and so
it's completely powered off
um and and so really i think one of the
things that
that i'm becoming more conscious about
as i'm as i'm spending more and more
time in there
is i don't want to i don't do anything
to to damage anything
as i'm going in and out and so um for
160 or
plus days 200 days whatever it is that
we're up here and i'm using that as my
bedroom
it's also what's going to get us home
and so i want to make sure i don't do
anything to compromise that
while i'm sleeping in there so i will
probably spend a lot
more time outside the crew quarters than
if i had or outside dragon
and if i had one of the crew quarters
that are in here so i think that is
that is an important piece of it that i
i don't ever want to forget
okay let's take a question again from
david curley with discovery channel
one more item on that mike uh are you
looking for them to send up some more
quarters i've heard them called if
they're attached to the floor of the
ceiling
coffins as you float over them they kind
of look like coffins phone booths on
them
and suici could you talk about what your
flight and john young mean to you
you've accomplished what your tarot your
mentor
did
okay um i guess i'll start yes there is
there is a plan
uh to have another crew quarters on
board it's called actually casa
um and and so it just it didn't make it
here in time there is a possibility that
that it might show up midway through um
the
the expedition and so if that is the
that is the case then i will uh
be moving out of resilience and and into
that uh crew quarter
and as i mentioned earlier i think
that's a good thing because i think we
want to just make sure we always keep
our
our return vehicles in pristine
condition
and uh and so anyway there is a plan
just not sure when it's going to
actually make it up here for that other
crew quarter
yeah again uh i'm very humbled an honor
to
to fly three vehicles uh uh after mr
john young
and also warri shira but the good thing
is uh many more is
ready to to follow actually in five
months from now the
crew two they have another two more
astronauts who fly the third
uh kind of space vehicle and the race
just begun for the who's gonna be the
first one to fly
four different one so watch out for that
all right let's take another question
from jeff wynn with cbs
los angeles hey victor uh thanks for
doing this one more question for you you
know in recent days you've talked about
social justice
and you've talked about the need for
kids to go into science
as you are circling the earth every 90
minutes what has that done to your
resolve
in terms of social justice and the
debate over extreme climate here
on earth
yeah that's you know jeff that's a great
but very very large question
i'll say this if anything it
strengthened my resolve in all of those
areas because i believe that
you know what what i've said and what
i've tried to work for is just what's
right
to to be honest and upfront with people
and then to work for what's right
and i think that doing the right thing
is always in order so um
you know looking at the planet from this
perspective actually i i went almost a
full day up here before i went and
looked
out the cupola in the daytime to see the
earth and
in these beautiful land masses and
oceans without lines or words drawn on
them
and um and also to look at it at dragon
it's it's beautiful
uh but it just it just heightens an
awareness that you know the planet needs
protection that human life needs
protection
uh and and we are the ones who have to
protect it
all right i think we could talk with you
all day but unfortunately that's all the
time we have for questions thank you so
much for
your time and for your answers today it
was
really great to talk with you we will
continue to keep up with your mission
online at nasa.gov station and by
following the station and nasa
sites on social media thanks for joining
everyone
thank you everyone
station this is houston acr that
concludes our event
thank you to all the participants from
nasa pao station we are now resuming
operational audio communications
[Music]
you